[Music]
hello and welcome
everyone to the actin flab guest stream
number 7.1.07.1 actually very nice
number
it's may 28 2021
and we have some very special guests on
today
who i will let themselves uh introduce
themselves
and then we'll go into a presentation
followed by a discussion so any and all
questions and comments just put into the
live chat during the presentation and
i'll be compiling those so that we can
make sure to ask them
so please miguel go for it
okay hi yeah i'm Miguel Aguilera i'm
working as a postdoc since a year now at
the university
university of sussex and
then so my name is Christopher Buckley
i'm a
lecturer at the university of sussex in
both the sussex neuroscience and sussex
ai groups
uh interested in sensory motor control
in general
cool so miguel um share your screen i'll
resize it
and then we'll have a presentation take
as long as you'd like
okay okay thanks a lot for the yeah for
the invitation i'm really happy to
present our work here and it's been
really kind of fast because
we just released the prayer print a few
days ago but it's and it's good for the
opportunity to
do this discussion online so far uh
okay let's see okay can you see my
screen
yep so and i'll resize it now so go for
it
okay okay so okay so this is this work
uh
so this is a problem that we have just
published as miguel aguilera and
and i we wrote it i wrote it with uh
alexander
alexander sons and christopher buckley
uh
from all from sussex but what's except
for brenda's now in oslo um
so the um so that they work just to
focus
on some of the recent publications about
the free energy principle
i guess most people watching know that
the pre-inner principle is
was conceived originally as a unified
brain theory
integrating experimental data and trying
to listen
to describe the relationship between
action perception
learning and so on and more recently the
theory has evolved and
and tried to become more general stating
that
any non-equilibrium dynamical system
under some special conditions can be
interpreted as performing by using
inference and this
will be a broader
theory of living system or a way to
describe
how certain living systems behave using
the tools from magician inference and
and okay so so this is kind of so in
principle this this kind of
schema of how a brain is predicting an
environment could be using different
systems like a cell or different
human beings and what i i imagine anyone
familiar with with the primary principle
have seen this kind of
pictures a lot and we're trying to
to to do different ones and yeah so i
think it's a
maybe a good thing to to to try to
visualize things in a new ways because
these ones have been repeated
done so many times um okay so so the
idea is so we are
interested in in exploring this the
the different assumptions behind the
principle because
um in in theory the free energy
principle applies to
a very diverse systems but in practice
there has been very few attempts to
explore it
to explore all the steps in the of the
theory in specific systems and
what we want to do here is just that and
we
want to understand the free energy
principle and its mathematical
assumptions in the
simplest system in the simplest
non-equilibrium system that we can find
and
this is a linear language dynamics that
i will explain later
and under an assumption of and the
assumptions that the couplings between
elements are weak
and in this very special case we can
compute all the relevant variables
analytically
and this will be a very again this is a
very interesting case for
studying in in-depth all the
mathematical
details um okay so the
the work i'm presenting today has is
related to the latest publications
around the ideas of the fib
the monograph of free energy for a
particular physics and the most
recent more recent paper uh by
thomas lance and carl about markov
blankets information geometry and
stochastic thermodynamics
and specifically we want to focus on on
two questions
the third question is is how general is
the free energy principle
that is uh from all the systems that we
can imagine
can capture aspects of biological
systems
how many of them conform to the
assumptions that
that the the principle requires
and the second question is how
informative is
the principle about the behavior of a
system so if if a system
if the first point holds so if a system
conforms to all the requirements of the
principle then
how much how much do we know about the
system right
how much uh the principle is able to
inform us about the behavior of this
organism okay so
so and and in this this we we find two
issues
that i will explain later in detail one
is that
and some of the requirements of of the
principle
uh are are make it challenging to find
systems in in the class of systems we
explore that that
find that that match the required
assumptions and
and the second issue we found is that
one important step in connecting the
behavior of the system to the
to the gradient of the free energy of
the sherlock principle
uh involves uh the coupling from the
history of interaction of a system
and this creates problems in the for
interpretation of a system behaving as
if minimizing apprentice i will
explain that into that so so before
starting
just one quick note on the notation we
are using which is a bit different from
from the papers and some of the
literature we are describing
external sensory active and internal
state with dc which is composed by
external states y
sensory states s active states a and
interval states
x and here also differently than in the
in the papers
both symbols represent a vector and
matrices
so and expectations instead which were
revolved in some of the papers here are
represented by these
m variables like my ms and so on
and sometimes the theory uses
conditional expectations given a blanket
state and in this case the
the blanket states the conditional state
is going to be between parentheses so
this is the
mean of y the mean of external states
given b
and also we can compute time derivatives
as usual
and we will represent marginal flows as
these f variables that i will describe
later
okay so so first we try to summarize the
different
conditions and assumptions that one
needs to derive the free energy
principle
and i am going to make a bit summary
which we will be useful for later
so first we the free energy principle
assumes we have a system that we can
describe
as a langevin stochastic differential
equation and this is just
having a noise term this omega which is
just random and
uncorrelated the white noise and some
flow function f that could be any
potentially non-linear function that
describes this time derivative this
evolution
this deterministic part of the evolution
of of a variable c
and in principle the the cubar er
omega's gaussian term and its covariance
is
just a diagonal matrix a gamma
because all the noise is independent
between elements
okay so the first condition that the the
free energy principle requires is that
the flow function decouples what the
it's generally called autonomous and
non-autonomous
states meaning that internal states
x are not going to influence external
and sensory states
and external states are not going to
influence active
and internal states and this so this is
what uh
what we generally expect from a sensory
motor loop in an agent
and so if we happen we represent this
evolution of the system like an euler
integration
so the external states do not influence
active and
internal and internal states do not
influence external and sensor
okay so so we are going to require
restrictor analysis to system that have
this
sensory model structure the second
condition of the principle is that
this system has a global attractor that
is that the
the probability distributions of the
state of a system converge
to some specific probability
distribution which is called t
and this speed and can be described by
the
surprise which is the negative logarithm
of this
of the probability which is how
surprising or how
unlikely is a state and
and the con this condition proposes that
this global attractor or this
steady-state distribution can be
described by a decomposition composition
helpful holds the composition or well an
a of the composition
which relates the flow function with the
surprise
via two matrices q and gamma gamma we
saw it before it was just the the
covariance of the noise
and q is a matrix capturing what's
generally called the solenoidal flows in
the system and
q is a it's asymmetric and the
solenoidal flows of the system mean mean
that uh it capture the non-equilibrium
influences in the system if if if a
system is at
thermodynamic equilibrium then q is
going to be zero
for all elements but if the system has
an
exchange of matter or energy or have
some asymmetry in the interaction
between the parts
q is going going to be non-zero okay
okay so we are going to have this and
this diffusion turns
gamma which are these these dot these
dust lines and then we are going to have
couplings between elements with these
solenoidal
influences that are captured by these uh
blue
arrows here this one will be arrows okay
so that's
the second condition and the last
condition that the free energy sport
requires is the mark of blanket
condition this
yeah maybe very well known which
requires that so that the sensory motor
states
s and a and which are generally called a
blanket state
with that we are going to call v
compressing the two
so the condition requires that this
variable
and are going to play a very special
role decoupling
internal external states in the
following way and they are going to
if if we compute a conditional
distribution
fixing b and of into external internal
states these states is going to be
independent
for a fixed v so they are not
independent in general but they are
independent for a specific
blanket state okay so we can yeah
so if these arrows are conditional our
statistical dependencies
the given b we have y and x but they are
not
and they are not statistically
correlated for a given b
okay and and so and in this sense the
these blanket states are going to be
like a a boundary or a barrier
between external and internal states
okay so so these are the conditions
required by the free energy principle in
orbit
meaning that these these are the
prerequisites that we
require so for a system to
uh to to to display the properties
uh proposed by the free energy principle
okay but asides of that uh we interpret
and that the theory has some three extra
assumptions
so these are not conditions these are
not presuppositive but things that
the theory expects to happen or expect
to find at least
in some some cases and
and for explaining this we still
explained before
and how the theory proposed that
and variational free energy is involved
in the behavior of a system
so so the free energy principle proposes
that any system under these conditions
that they describe
can be seen as minimizing or as if
it's going to behave as if minimizing a
variational free energy
so for and for defining this free energy
we start with the surprise
of the blanket state so the blanket
state is is what an agent can observe
in the environment the agent uh do not
cannot access the environment directly
because of the essential metastructure
that we have
but only can access the blanket states
the sensors and the actuators
and and if a system is is
behaving as if minimizing the free
energy or
and doing variation inference assistant
will is going to behave
as if minimizing the um
yeah the the surprise of this this state
and okay but the but the system cannot
access this probability
probability distribution directly but
because it doesn't really cannot access
the environment
so instead of that by using inference
prescribes to use a lower bound
of this surprise and okay which is
called a variational free energy
and this variation of free energy
consists of on the surprise term
plus some divergence with some kl
divergence between the
actual probability distribution of the
environment given the blanket
and a model q a simplified model of the
environment
and and by ambassador inference consists
in finding the parameters theta of this
model
that minimize this distance so in this
so when this distance is minimized then
the agent
has a model of the world and is
predicting
the the states of the environment white
okay so
so solving the digestion inference
problem
uh so the simplest way of simplest way
of doing it is just
doing a gradient descent minimization of
this free energy
which ends up in being a gradient
descent of of the surprise
of the environment y at at the most
likely state
theta and blanket okay so so here just
theta just parameterizes the most likely
state of y
okay um okay so so then the the
frequency principle defines the most
likely states of the
uh of the system and environment peaks
in a blanket
just like the the mode or the arc max
but sometimes it has been proposed that
the mean is enough
for doing this and since we are going to
use linear systems
they both are going to be the same so
you can interpret this m as the mode or
as the
as the mean of of y and x given b
and then you can if you remember we have
these flow functions
f you can compute the average flow of
the system
and y for a given b and
which we saw in this assumption that can
be described by this matrix q and gamma
and the gradient
on the surprise so if we want to find
something like the gradient
of the surprise that we have here and
the
free energy principle proposes that we
have to compute the average of
of the flow given b and we obtain
something like this
and and we can see here that the first
term is just what we want is the
gradient
is sorted with the gradient of the
surprise but we have some extra terms
um and so if we have
so if we have some some gradient like
this
we could if we had something like the
first term in this equation we could
interpret we can use this orient
to perform um
we will use this way to perform a
minimization of this energy which
interpret if we interpret it
and strictly it could mean having some
variable theta that
follows this gradient oh sorry one
second
and okay and
okay so so if we have some okay so and
the effect
the free energy so suggest that this
parameters theta is going to be the most
likely
states of external or then internal
states
i'm going to do so so we have sorry we
have this equation here this equation 12
and we just need the first term so in
general the free energy principle
proposes that
uh the the couplings of this matrix q
the non di
um are going to be zero and
okay so so okay so this is uh
so each element in this diagonal is a
block can have many a number of
dimensions
and the free energy principle assumes
that
well one interpretation is that it
assumes that
removing these solenoidal couplings
these non-block diagonal
copings then we are going to remove
these elements that we don't want
and we are going to have a flow of the
system
uh equal to this gradient on the
surprise that is the gradient that
minimize the free energy
okay so so this is the first assumption
if if this
if these q terms are equal to zero then
we have an average flow that goes in the
direction of minimizing the free energy
and this is interesting because we will
have a system that points in the
uh in the direction of the free energy
and what we
i will explain that later and however
there's in some works
uh it is proposed that the there's a
more general form of this matrix that is
not
it's also block diagonal but not within
y and sna but
within uh autonomous and non-autonomous
states
and a and x and and this is has been
referred as the general case but
it's not for us at least it's not that
clear how
you can derive in this case and this
gradient of the free energy and
what it suggested that the solenoidal
couplings can
cancel out but but yeah but i
so we are going to consider the two
cases but uh considers
in principle just the the case of a
complete
diagonal so this first assumption means
that the solenoidal coatings between
elements
are or can be approximated as zero
okay and the second assumption
is the and okay so we have a flow of
external states that's pointing in the
direction of minimizing the free energy
but we want to interpret internal states
as minimizing this free energy
so what the free energy small purpose
purposes to solve this
so the the proposal is that there is a
a smooth mapping sigma that connects the
most likely internal states with the
most likely external states
so this m y is equal to sigma x
and and the assumption is that there's a
gradient
and of the of yeah there's a gradient or
there's a derivative of this mapping
that exists so the mapping is
differentiable and that it is invertible
and they propose that the sufficient
requisite for this assumption too is
that the mapping from b
to mx is injected okay and
so if this mapping exists then we can
connect the
external states with the internal states
and we know that the external states
about flow that points in the direction
of minimizing the free energy
and so the hope is that now internal
states
if this mapping exists are going also to
have a flow that's pointing in the
direction of the free energy
and the last assumption and this is
maybe more controversial
is that if one have a
strict interpretation of the
gradient descent on of a free energy
and the the assumption will be
that the dynamics of the most likely
states are approximately equal to the
dynamic to the average flow of the
external state
so so this is the derivative of the
average state
and the right side will be the average
of the derivative to some so so
so this is saying something like this no
proximity the derivative of the rate is
going to be
equivalent to the average of the
derivative because the flow is just the
the time derivative of the of the system
uh so and if this assumption will be
true then
not only the flow of external states
point in the direction of the primary
but also
the dynamics of the system of the uh are
minimizing the free energy
and and this is interesting because if
we had this
if this is true then we have some
equation like this
so the derivative of uh of time y is
equal to the gradient respect to n y of
this surprise
so the dynamics of m y are behaving as
if minimizing
the free energy so we so this equation
is true we know that the dynamics of the
behavior of the system is going to be
minimizing
actively performing a gradient descent
on the free energy
and if this is true and we have the
mapping that
assumption two proposed then we can use
the chain rule
to find a connection between between the
derivative of m y
and the derivative of n y so the
dynamics of the external states and the
dynamics of the internal states
just with the gradient of this sigma
function
so this is just a chain rule of the of
derivatives
and with this step then we can describe
the dynamics of internal states as the
dynamics of external states and use this
gradient mapping to reach this equation
that tells you that the dynamics of the
most likely internal states
is doing a gradient descent on the free
energy so this is the end of the
of the of the argument of the free
energy so so if this is true then
the internal states will be behaving as
if minimizing
the free energy about external states
and then the
internal state will be behaving as if
effectively performing uh by a budgeting
inference
okay and and well we derived that from
some of the
the steps in in these publications in
the
the monograph of a particular free
energy for a particular physics and the
most recent
uh paper based formats about markov
blankets information geometries and so
on
because they or at least it appeared to
us that
they were using the same symbol for the
derivative of external states and the
average flow
and because so in some equations there
is a connection between the any so
for the chain rule they use this the
symbol and point
and so so this is why we
interpret this in the in this way
however
and also from conversation from the
authors
uh it's proposed that the
the free energy principle is not exactly
proposing that the behaviors
so i need the presentation of the
principle will be that the
system is not doing any straight
creating descent as this assumption
three
that we label with this star because
it's
in part or interpretation but that the
an alternative to this assumption star 3
will be assumption star star 3
which is that it is not the
derivative of the most likely state that
follow the grain of the free energy but
that but just the flow
the average flow so the average flow of
f y
is just the average of the derivative of
y given v the conditional average with
the conditional distribution
and and the claim will be that
if the flow is pointing so if the
average derivative
is pointing in the right direction of
the free energy then
you can interpret that the system is
behaving
as if on average it was performing a
gradient descent
so so this assumption on star star 3
would be that
not that the system is exactly doing a
gradient descent on the free energy
but that it is doing on average now if
we will have
like many observations of of the system
then we could see that they on average
points to a minimization of the free
energy but maybe not if we just observe
one system individually
okay and then this assumption starts
start three will be that
yeah exactly that now if the conditional
average flows follow the direction of
uh gradient descendant on the free
energy then the behavior can be
described on average
as if minimizing the greenhouse okay
okay so this is the summary of the
different conditions and assumptions
of the principle in which we will have
competing interpretations at some points
like this assumption three
um okay um okay this is a lot of steps
and
and it is hard to intuitively
have an idea of of what goes
what yeah how we can expect from any of
them so
what we did is we try to explore these
different conditions and assumptions
in a in a very easy system to solve and
and and see what we can expect uh in
this
very simple case no so our ideas the
best way to really understand this
is to have a toy model the the same
place we can have
and and see how easy or hard
is for the different assumptions to
behold to be held by the system
okay so we substituted the langiban
dynamics that we had before
by just a linear language so everything
is the same
and well we have a factor for the noise
but this is going to be this one and
and we have we have uh
now the f function the flow is just
substituted by
a linear multiplication so we have a
matrix j
which is an invertible unreal which is
multiplying
the state of the system minus some
constant raw which is just going to be
the
an offset capturing the the average
state in
a steady state okay and this system is
going to be a non-equilibrium system
if and the matrix j is
is not symmetric okay so in that case we
are going to have a non-equilibrium
system
and we are going to have like for
example spiral flows and so on
and the interesting thing is that this
system has a
has a steady state if we let the system
run for some time it's going to have a
steady state that's going to be a
gaussian distribution because if
everything is linear
and the noise is linear eventually the
system is going to reach
a steady state gaussian distribution and
in the
limit of time time going to infinity
the average of this gaussian is going to
be just this row parameter
and the covariance matrix of this
multiplied gaussian is going to be this
sigma star matrix
and and this sigma star matrix cannot be
solved uh analytically but it's the
solution of this equation 29
it's an equation that involves the noise
the covariance of the noise gamma
and the couplings yeah and if
in equilibrium this matrix these
equations can be solved analytically but
we are interested in more generally in
non-equilibrium systems and
this this equation is called a
continuous line of lyapunov equation
and in principle it can be just solved
numerically
which is not ideal for us because we
want to
access to have the connections between
the parameters and
and the matrix but we cannot in general
okay so what what did we do um
so in order to have a solution of this
equation a general solution
we assume the following we assume that
and
the couplings of j can be defined
as some diagonal term i
and this is negative just to ensure the
stability of the system so if
if if y if i is is positive and large
then you will have a diverging system
and then we have a non-diagonal
couplings
c and we assume that these c terms
are small so if we have c square or
c to the power of three and these are
going to be neglectable terms
and in that sense we can so we have that
we can solve this equation
you know in terms of a power series
expansion so we can have like a
so this will be equivalent to a taylor
expansion that you can
see in calculus and and
we can have an expression of this sigma
the covariance matrix of the solution in
terms
of increasing powers of c
so we have here the linear term the
quadratic terms and
some cubic terms that we are going to
ignore
okay and to make things more easier we
are going to assume that the
noise is homogeneous so sigma is just
identity matrix times some constant some
scanner constant
okay so
okay so we choose values of so if
y so the conditions one and two are
almost automatically um true if
y is not even larger than c we have a
global attractor
and also we can define j
to have the sensory motor structure that
we want
and so we go directly to condition three
so condition three is the markov blanket
condition
proposing that the blanket states or the
central motor states play a very special
role
being a boundary between external states
and internalistics so that the
distributes the conditional distribution
is an independent
distribution given the blanket y and x
are independent
okay so in a gaussian distribution
and this condition is true if another
leaf
the hessian matrix which is the inverse
of the covariance
satisfies that the decision between y
and x decision between internal
and external states remember that this
can be a matrix if the dimensions of y
and x are more than one
it's equal to zero and okay so
we can very easily compute uh
what's the form of discretion with these
approximations so
we have the question how common are
markov blankets now from all the systems
in the world
and how often can we expect
if we have just random parameters to
find our
markov blanket okay so we want this
matrix
h which is the inverse of the covariance
of the steady state distribution
and we can express this inverse
again as a power series and this is
called a neumann series
for computing the inverse of a matrix
and
and it has this form we have again a
linear term
and a quadratic term and some cubic
terms that we are going to ignore
okay and so we just need to know c
to know how what's h and to know if this
corner of the matrix is equal to zero
okay
so so c is going to be like this because
we impose
these specific sensor motor structures
in which external states don't influence
internal and internal done influence
external and so on
and so for the first order approximation
we have this equation 36 okay so so you
yeah for a third sort of approximation
we just
keep this term of the equation and we
can see
which is c plus the transpose just
switching
rows and columns and we can see that if
we
sum c plus the transpose the term in the
corner is going to be equal to zero
which is what what we want so for our
first order approximation we have a
an exact markov blanket and the markov
blanket is always going to be true so
this is
a good news in principle and however
if we if we are a little what if we want
more precision
and we compute a second order so we get
this quadratic terms here
we find that the corner of the hessian
the one that has to be zero has this
form
so in principle this is not going to be
zero or is
going to be zero just for various
special cases
and if we look at the connectivity
structure of the of the system
so the kind of sensor motor loop that we
require in general
is this a canonical loop
at figure a so in principle for this
structure
very few systems are going to have a
markov blanket because this is
not going to be zero exactly almost
never
and however there is some other
configurations that are going to have a
mark of language if we have a circular
loop like this case b
or we have something like this a
structure in c
then uh the relevant then then the terms
appearing in this equation are
at least one of them is zero in both
cases and this is going to be zero so
v and c are going to have a markov
blanket in general but
not a and there are second order
approximation
and so under this canonical flow
constraint so case a
only a few systems are going to display
an exact
mark of blankets although about one
exception are going to be the circular
loops or the symmetric loops
and however we we fair we we have to say
that um
in the case of weak couplings uh the
markov blanket is still going to be a
reason
princeton or reasonable approximation
because if we have some equation like
this and
so so so the first term so so even if we
have something like this this is a
second order equation
and all the other elements in the matrix
are going to have first order components
that are going to be much larger so even
if it's
even if we do not have an exact markov
blanket this is going to be a reasonable
reasonable approximation
in most cases okay
so this is condition one conditional
three sorry so let's go to the next
the next one is assumption one uh which
states that
uh the solenoidal couplings between
blocks of state
have to be zero in order to have a
flow that points in the direction of the
free energy or we could relax this
assumption and have this
this larger blocks but also we're
requiring some some zeros in here
uh okay and so we can rewrite the the
previous solution of the
of the steady state equation uh to find
an exp
a connection between q gamma and j
and we and doing that will reach right
in the previous equation we can reach
this equation
40. and again and this is this equation
can
cannot be solved directly in general
because it's another
continuous like upon equation but
assuming uh that we have j equal
c minus y like and the coordinates are
small as we have before
we can do the same trick and have a new
power series that connects
q with the values of c okay and has this
form which is
similar but a little bit different than
the case before
um okay so but this case looks a little
bit more complicated so first we just
computed the
the first order expansion of q
and it looks like this so so this is q
for a first order
case ignoring this the quadratic terms
of c okay and again
we see that there is in principle few
cases
where then yeah where the assumption
is held exactly because we are
we're having you we want to make zero
all these terms here
and if we don't constrain the possible
parameters this is going
to be true only in very very special
cases
and we can see that one way to make zero
many elements of this matrix
is assuming that they are symmetric if c
and y s is equal to the transpose of t
so so if the connections from
sensor to environment are equal to the
connections of environment to sensor
then this is going to be zero
and in that case we obtain this matrix
which has a lot of zeros but still there
is these terms
that we cannot get rid of so if these
couplings are not zero
then uh we don't have the assumption of
the free energy principle and
and this is important because well this
is well this is this will be the
the connection from actuators to the
environment which in principle is
something we could
expect in many cases and this is the
uh yeah and this is the connections from
sensor
to internal states which is also
something we expect in most
sensory motor or we intuitively expect
from a cognitive system with a sensory
motor loop
and if we want to make these elements of
the matrix
equal to zero then we
need to have something like this loop c
in which these elements are symmetric
the js
the non-diagonal js are symmetric and
also we
remove the connections from sensor to
internal states and actuators to
external state which is
intuitively uh a bit strange but but
i think is in some of the literature of
the friner events with this kind of loop
has been used
and so and it has probably and it has
purpose that this could represent for
example the
the membrane of a cell that separates
the
internal and external states in this
kind of symmetric
manner although i think there is some
well there's some research on cell
membranes indicating that
asymmetries in them in membranes are
still important so this could be still
a potential issue for finding systems
that
that that have this this zero this block
that you're gonna help you
and if we consider the second order
approximations things become
spookier and we have many many terms
and we see that these elements are just
going to be zero in very
in a very narrow set of of cases which
is
potentially problematic for for
uh yeah for asserting that the principle
is
is in general for it would yeah this
assumptions will be general for
for many systems and this
also gives you an idea that we we are
starting this very special
case with very weak couplings but having
a
stronger couplings in principle will
make things
more complicated and not easier
and okay so this is assumption one and
we only are going to get this block
diagram they're very specific
circumstances and this as the only
exception being this symmetric
loop with this very very special
structure
and so so this is so imp so in
conjunction the markov blanket
exploration and the
and the exploration of these soldiers
accomplish uh will
indicate that under the class of systems
that we studied the
the free energy principle will be will
only emerge exactly for a very narrow
set
of systems okay so so this is um
so interesting to think about how
general the principle is or how can we
expect
it to be to be found in in in different
classes of systems
although we just restricted our analysis
to these linear ones
um okay so the second assumption and
connected to the question of
how general not not how general but how
informative the system
is and the second assumption is is that
we have this mapping between internal
external states and
and if we compute the most likely
international states given a blanket
for a gaussian distribution we can do it
very easily to computing a conditional
average
and so these are the questions you can
find it in any
textbook multivariate gaussians
and we find that if this
requires to compute the generalized
inverse of some matrix
and and we find that
we can in linear systems and
in some cases if the kernels of these
matrix
are correct and we can derive the
mapping but these mappings
if we have the correct dimensionality
will exist very broadly
so this mapping is just going to be a
linear matrix multiplication
of the relation between m y
and mx so so this is good news and first
of all this mapping exists and it can be
expected to be
very broad if the dimensions of these
variables are are correct
although maybe yeah maybe we should know
that in some of the literature that
some of the verbal descriptions say that
this mapping
and it's a consequence of the
marketplace but what we found here is
that
they are principally independent they
they could
emerge even if there is not a markov
blanket so
at least in linear systems uh and also
this
we we discovered that this result was
also found
in independently but by lance the
costine award
that is going to be published soon and
it's i think that they
they got to the exact same result as we
did
uh okay so so going to the last
assumption which is maybe
the most complicated and
so the last step of the free energy
principle was to
say that we know that the flow of
external state the average flow y
is pointing in the direction of the free
energy and this means
that the system is behaving as if
minimizing the free energy
and i described that there is two
possible interpretations for this
an extrict one and a relaxed one so
let's explore first the
strict gradient descent interpretation
which would
mean that the derivative of the average
of the external states is equal to the
average flow
and we can compute that very easily in
our linear system this this equation is
the derivative of the average state
and this equation is just the average
flow
and what we did for comparing both is
just generating a dummy variable this
tilde m which behaves
as equally as the average flow so this
this variable tilde n
will be a variable that strictly
minimizes the free energy
right so so we have so this is the real
dynamics
of this of these study of these most
likely states
and this is what these most likely
stages will do if they were exactly
minimizing the free energy
and under or we copied approximations we
can see that we can
get to simplified version of these
equations
and we can see that both of them are a
bit different
at first the real dynamics has a noise
noise term because the fluctuations are
going to affect the dynamics because the
the observations of the blanket are true
by noise
so this is going to be a noisy dynamics
and this is not
and the second difference is that this
term changes
the sign here so here is positive and
here is negative
and this seems strange but the the
reason of this is because
and this so this is the real dynamics
which depends on the previous state and
this
average flow it's his story
independence in some sense it just
depends on the previous state of b
but it doesn't depend on the previous
state of y
so to speak so
so in that sense the the structure of
the of the
flow of this variable of the dynamics of
this variable is going to be different
and in this case this difference is
captured
by this constant that has a different
sign between one and the other
and if we run a simulation of both of
both equations we find that the behavior
is
is very different and so this is the
behavior of the real average
variables so this is a system with two
dimensions
and you have the symmetric forms because
the the we restricted
the couplings to plus minus 0.1
and if we represent this tilde m so so
this is
the system that strictly minimizes the
free energy we have this very very
different behavior
which has this kind of a random walk and
and this is because this this variable
is integrating the fluctuations of of
the other one
and so the so the error keeps
accumulating and
and the behavior is very different so
in principle it's unlikely that the and
and these results were similar for many
combinations of parameters but in
principle is
unlikely that the dynamics of the most
likely states are going to
be um so that the average flow is going
to be informative about the actual
dynamics
of the most likely states okay so this
is the strict version of the assumption
the relaxed version
would be that only the average flow
follows the gradient of the free energy
and if we if we interpret this
we find that there is two problems at
least we thought that there is two
problems
and the first problem is that a key step
of the free energy principle uses the
synchronization manifold
so the sigma function connected external
and translates
and then derives a chain rule connecting
the
dynamics of my with the dynamics of
internal states
and and this leads to saying that the
flow of the internal states
is following the gradient of the free
energy
okay and so if we say that the
free energy does not truly apply to the
time derivatives
of the most likely state but just
applies to the flow
then we cannot use the sigma
mapping to the right this equivalence
between what the external states are
doing and what the internal states are
doing
and so we cannot so this step becomes
problematic
and if we want to connect the flows of
internal states and the flows of
external states as the as the energy
principle proposes
then one will need a new mapping because
this mapping
and this mapping are not the same and we
computed
in nonlinear system the two mappings and
we find that the
the mapping has a different expression
and it is different
from the mapping that's the gradient of
the mapping that's used in the
literature
so so in principle this relax
interpretation will require
uh a different mapping that's different
than sigma because we are
not interested on the flows of the most
likely states but on just on these
average flows
and okay
sorry yeah uh and well and more
importantly uh
another problem arises which is
um yeah sorry so
so if we have an a street
uh sorry one second
yeah if we have a strict interpretation
of the
uh okay sorry i lose this uh yeah if we
have a strict interpretation
like this like a of okay internal states
are following a gradient are doing a
gradient descent
on the on the free energy so the
derivative the temporal derivative is
equal to the gradient
of the so this is uh this is a
definition of uh
like a textbook greek in descent okay
and this is fine
if we have this equation we know that
the system is doing a gradient descent
so the question is if we just have
this equation here so the average flow
is pointing in the direction of the
gradient
can we really interpret that the system
is behaving as if minimizing the free
energy so
how informative is this average flow
about the real behavior so we try to
explore this
so first and so well first in the
simulations we see that
it may be little informant there yeah it
would be little informative even if we
had a different mapping
and maybe this average flow has little
information about
what the actual dynamics is doing and
for exploring this further and you can
see it in the in an appendix so for
for a preparant like this the second
appendix uh we try to to explore what is
the connection between the average flow
and the actual dynamics of the system uh
in a very simple system so we restricted
our system to a bi-dimensional case
with this non-equilibrium behavior this
is so this the flows of the system are
have this spiral behavior with under
noise are going to be
rotating in this muscle so we have two
variables y
and b and so this is the flow the actual
flow of the system
and we ask okay so in this system what
is the the dynamics of the most likely
states
so this derivative of m y and given v
and we find that we have this negative
slope which is
uh well you have this this pink area
because this is a random variable which
is going to have noise and
it's going to be noisy and so on but on
average we have
this negative slope meaning that
the system is going to be minimizing
it's going to have an attractor at zero
right if you
study dynamical systems and have a
negative slope of a derivative
or at least on average you are going to
minimize
so if the state is negative you are
going to reduce it you are going to
increase it sorry
and if the state is positive you are
going to reduce it so you are going to
have an attractor at 0 which is what we
see
in the actual system but
at least for some combinations of
parameters which we were like
half of the possible combinations of
parameters that we tried
if you compute the average flow it gives
you the opposite behavior here the slope
is positive
meaning that if you have a system that
follows this slope
is going to diverge to ma plus infinity
or minus infinity
so this is intended as an example that
the average flow can be a very poor
description
of the actual behavior of a system if
what you have
is a stochastic dynamical system
and okay so
so in general we cannot assume that
under all circumstances
the marginal flow is going to be
informative as the behavior of a system
and if
even if you can derive all the steps or
of the free energy principle it might be
the case that in some systems
the average flow that's pointing is
pointing in the direction of the free
energy
but the system is not behaving as
minimizing the free energy you know you
can see it in this example
uh the system is minimizing
the value of y square it's going to zero
not the
here the value of of these variables is
going to zero but
the average flow points in the opposite
direction it tells you that
if the average flow if you interpret the
average flow as what the system is
doing then you will believe that the
system is maximizing
the square value of y for example
because it's diverging and what it's
doing is just minimizing it because it's
going to zero
okay and so
in principle if the if the dynamics of
the most likely states and the
and the average flow are different then
uh yeah so they can they they are going
to be in general difference and
in that case they are not going to be
informative what
about the behavioral system except in
various
maybe very specific cases as mean field
approximations or this kind of thing
and and this difference is because the
these marginal flows arise from a
decoupling of a previous
history of the system and they are not
considering the effect
of the effects of fluctuations and
fluctuations okay
and okay so just to finish and maybe
let's give
place to the discussion and
when this work we explore the conditions
to and the assumptions that are needed
to
derive the free energy principle in
linear non-equilibrium stochastic
systems and
and some of this has been explored for
specific
counterexamples as a recent work by
martin bill and
others but i think it's interesting that
we did this for a
general class of systems so it's not one
example that we saw numerically but we
solve a family of weekly co systems and
we see
how general or not are the different
assumptions
and so first we explore that we explore
how general
are these conditions and assumptions of
the principle
and then we study under what conditions
can we expect
and the principle to be informative
about the behavior of a system
and first we found that the markov
blanket condition
emerged at least as a good
approximations in the case of weak
weak couplings but if the couplings are
not super weak are not very weak
then we maybe we cannot expect to be
exact
in yeah in general and
however solenoidal couplings are
generally present in all blocks of the
system so
so and they you are going to be serious
in very very special cases as this
symmetric loop
so maybe a direction of two of the for
the theory will be to
yeah to explain exactly what happens
when these these
and coppers are not zero and and what
yeah what
happens in that case and
and so in conclusion we see that only
very specific structures are going to
satisfy
their requirements uh to derive the
the to the right that the average flow
is pointing in the direction of the free
energy
and the second point about how
informative the principle is
we saw that the connection between the
free energy
and the marginal flow of the system with
the behave the actual behavior of a
system is
is in most cases very very weak or even
contradictory as one can
point in one direction and the other in
the other
so we found that this in general these
marginal flows are not capturing the the
actual dynamics of the system and
and this is because the this marginal
flow is ignoring the history of
interactions and
we could intuitively think about this
so we will have a so we can imagine a
system that
has many trajectories and if we fix the
blanket at some point
it just means uh having different
trajectories that are going to pass
through this point
and the average flow is just going to
compute the directions or the direction
of the
most likely derivative at that point
well the average derivative of the
system at that point
but an any individual system can have a
very different behavior which is
represented by black line here
and so an intuitive example for this
uh could be the uh to distinguish
between the
the population of an individual organism
organization and the world
and the behavior of a population and so
you could think that the
on average uh a population of organisms
is
is behaving in a way that's maximizing
evolutionary fitness
but this can be largely an informative
for describing the behavior of
individual organisms not that some
sometimes the kind of criticisms that we
hear and
to some proposals in a person
evolutionary psychology and this kind of
thing right
so so even if i at an average macro
level
you can detect some tendencies in
many cases these tendencies can be
uninformative about
what an individual is doing right and so
so we think that it's
interesting to to think about uh
if and when and in which cases the
the the conclusion the conclusions
derived by the free energy principle are
going to be
informative about the behavior of
an individual or or groups of
individuals and so on
still we we have to say that um
even if we did this what kind of
critical
evaluation we are still we find that the
the the motivation of the free energy
principle is
is very it's very suggestive and and
we think that the the aim of connecting
ideas from variational inference with
the dynamics of complex
self-organization system is tremendously
important as
it could allow to apply the machinery of
magician and information theory
to describe systems that are intractable
in practice but
but we also think that it's some how
difficult to just write
a theory and without a connection to
specific models right that can allow you
to
to inspect in more detail some
assumptions or some consequences of the
assumptions that
are difficult to grasp intuitively in
many cases right
and and so
so in principle we find that the yeah
that it will be interesting to
yeah that exemplifying the steps of the
theory in a specific model
is very useful to to
yeah it's very useful to understand the
connections between steps and
how likely or not are different steps
and that this can this kind of exercise
can be
only useful too and yeah to to to do
yeah it can be really useful to to and
understand the kind of
uh the difficulties that we face
for even a theory and just one so this
is the
the preprint that we just published how
particular is the physics of the free
energy
um thanks a lot
thank you
thanks for this awesome presentation
there was
a lot there and it was incredibly well
presented
so for those who are watching live i
would invite them to
write questions in the chat but first um
chris
i'll just pass it to you for an initial
comments if you would like
oh unmute then please continue
wait chris you're admitted and then
continue
yeah so miguel that the we even though
we we found these
laws in a particular kind of technical
presentation we've seen we still
find that the kind of the the ambition
of the
uh uh free energy principle is laudable
right and we're really it's something we
really want to embrace but yet we feel
that it needs uh some future
development right so i mean i summarize
there's two issues that
miguel has presented here the first one
is the problem about trying to
characterize the interaction of an agent
with its environment so you can do this
in two ways
and one typical way is to draw kind of
connections and direct
functional connections between an agent
and environment right so the sensors and
the motors and so on
uh well there is a different way of
understanding those interactions in
terms of the
testing or the covariance matrix which
kind of describe correlation system
rather than direct connections
and i think what uh carl has done is
kind of
really work from the hessian upwards
rather than considering
the functional connections that underlie
and underlie those two
underlie those right so he wants to
assume there is a markup blanket and
wants to start there
and and then he's not so concerned about
trying to work out the class of systems
that meets those conditions and i think
that's a valid thing to do
it might be a very special set of
systems but i think carl will claim
that's the kind of systems i'm
interested in i'm not really interested
in those other systems right and
what we've pointed out is that we can't
find those uh
very generally in in the class of
systems
uh and the second major issue that i
think uh miguel's work points out
is this decoupling between the
description of the deterministic
dynamics
of the system versus the average
dynamics of an ensemble of systems right
so in prior accounts of the free energy
principle you actually write the
deterministic dynamics into your
description so when you're using for
energy principle to do cognitive systems
you are describing the certain
deterministic dynamics directly
in terms of your expectations and and uh
and flows on your expectations but what
the particular physics approach wants to
do is try to
try to find that deterministic dynamics
within the physics right it wants to see
where it
where it would lie within the kind of
general stochastic dynamical systems
theories of physics and that's where the
problems lie right so it's very hard to
go from
the the physics to the description in
terms a good description of the system
in terms of the kind of
uh dynamics on expectations and and so
on in that system
so we find this problem of a decoupling
between
the description and the dynamics of the
uh the the moments of a system versus
the average over an ensemble of systems
this is where where the problem lies
right
so the over ensemble systems the free
energy might be a good description but
it's not connected
to the causal explanation of the
dynamics of a specific system so you
can't attribute
kind of the uh the right kind of
mechanistic description to that
particular system that you would like to
uh and yeah so i'm that's kind of my
summary maybe
thank you for the succinct summary
that's very helpful for many i'm sure
claren if you'd like to um unview sorry
i heard a feedback when
chris was speaking so if you can unmute
or
uh yep okay yeah introduce yourself and
then give any comments you'd like and
then i'll go to the questions
yes bro so hi i'm ben i'm obviously an
author on this and i'm currently now a
postdoc in oxford but i worked very
closely with
uh chris and miguel at sussex for a long
time
so yeah also simon later had something
else scheduling conflicts i just
jumped in for the questions but yeah so
i would just
like i think chris did an excellent job
of explaining the issue with the average
dynamics
versus the dynamics of the average but i
would just like to go in and kind of
reiterate to me
an important thing about the markup
blankets is really this idea that the
markup
there is a huge distinction between the
sort of statistical independence
relationships
and this kind of like causal actual
relationship you get if you write out
the dynamics
and so it's quite easy to confuse these
two and indeed i think we
we naturally conflated these two a lot
until we started writing this paper
and a lot of the literature also like
conflates these two and you know they
have these intuitive diagrams of you
know like
the bacteria with its cell wall and
everything and that's the blanket and so
forth
but that's in this causal level of the
description like in the things cause we
have to pass through the blank but
that's not the same at all
as the statistical description which is
you know the statistical independencies
between you know the blanket and the
intel and the external states and i
think yeah
it needs quite a lot of thinking about
what extent these causal mappings
actually hold up and sort of actually
sustained by the statistical mappings or
vice versa and we've found in linear
systems there's a lot of cases
where they don't and they don't seem to
matter at all and so yeah it takes a lot
of
kind of different intuitions really i
think need to be built about
what these markup blankets mean and
actuals will cause a level
thanks for this comment and again people
can write questions
if i could just actually add something
about the difference between the causal
structure and the correlative structure
you could imagine
on a market there's companies that are
causally related to each other but their
stock prices
are not correlated and similarly in the
cell
we often make networks that are based
upon like gene co-expression
so genes with correlated expression and
then there's gene regulatory networks or
protein protein interaction networks
that are like proteins that touch but
those proteins usually don't have
correlated expression because you might
up regulate one that then represses
another so they're not expressed in a
correlated fashion but they have causal
relationships
so and it's people slipping between oh
gene regulatory network you know
co-expression
interactions certainly conflating
the causal structure of a system with
the physical structure or the
correlative structure
is a broad category error and i think
your work
does an incredible job at highlighting
the difference
and where slipping between these easily
confusible modes of thinking about
networks
and then also conflating that with
reality or all of reality
just very well done to these points
yeah thanks yeah another example would
be like the difference between
structural connectivity
and functional connectivity and
effective connectivity in in
in the brain right you can have some
structure but and then you can have
statistical correlations but
even then the dynamics can behave
differently because you have like these
asymmetries in in how one variable is
connected to another and
on the opposite end and this is also not
work the relation with the solenoidal
flows that
capture something different than so yeah
so it's
you know very complicated to disentangle
all these different levels and
but you just justice to the office i
mean i think they're aware of
this difference obviously uh carl's
group is very aware of this difference
but they they feel that the theory sits
above that right at the correlative
structures and not considering
uh those causal structures i think maybe
some confusion might have emerged in
previous papers but in recent papers i
think it's very clear that they want to
sit above
the causal corrections cool
so i hope that by bringing the math to
examples of like the market evolution
um and fmri we can hopefully have a lot
of people
giving their perspective so i'm gonna
just go with a question from the chat
and then i have some questions that i
wrote down so uh first question
thanks a lot i was wondering whether you
would assume
that going to non-linear systems the
limitations that you find
would be even stronger or would there
may be an argument that there could be
non-linear systems that fulfill these
assumptions so what will relaxing the
linear assumption do for the math that
you described today
okay well that's that's a difficult to
to answer a question in general i think
so
so okay so so first is is i think it's
it's difficult to well it's difficult to
solve because
uh in nonlinear systems in general
we cannot find the kind of analytical
solutions that we have here right and
and even in the case of linear systems
we found
that we can only solve the case of weak
copies
and in the case of weak couplings
we could do the trick of considering
different orders of expansions
and we saw that including stronger
couplings make
things more difficult rather than rather
than easier
okay and intuitively uh
at least my intuition about non-linear
systems is is that
the case may be my may be similar in
many systems right right
having strong that yeah having
more intricate couplings more intricate
dynamical couplings could add
extra turns uh to some of the matrices
that we are expecting to
be zero like in the markov blanket and
but
still this is not something we can say
because or you will have
i know unexpected effects from chaos for
example and i think
that's something that carl proposes
sometimes
and but i don't know i think maybe one
interesting
direction of research will be doing
a similar expansion to the one that we
did
to say okay we have an almost linear
system but we consider
very small effects of non-linearity and
see
what kind of terms this adds to the
to the matrices that we are so this this
could involve a very different
analytical
solution but i i think there is some up
for coming work
and from uh yeah from
some people in cars working in that
sense so so i think it's
an open questions but but i intuitively
think that in many cases this is going
to be challenging to
to continue yeah to see that
non-linearity is going to
be a solution um i mean you feel the
intuition is that you might be able to
solve it in specific
systems uh but you know you start
but the idea that you'll solve it in a
classic non-linear system seems
seems uh doubtful right but you might be
able to find examples
which you augment with nonlinearities
that meet the criteria
maybe if you constrain yourself to a
particular evolved uh
living system that might be okay right
but if you want to say something
more general about the emergency self
organization in the classroom
physical systems they perhaps run into
trouble
two thoughts yeah we'll go ahead and
first
yeah i agree with chris and that
obviously with non-linear systems you
have a much bigger space of systems
and so you can probably find you know
edge cases where all the conditions
match perfectly
but i mean the general intuition you
dynamical systems is the non-linear
systems are a lot harder to deal with
in general and so i'm not going to
probably you know if it's not satisfied
in linear systems there's no obvious
reason why it should be satisfied in
non-linear systems
and especially the issue with the the
dynamics of the average versus the
average of the dynamics
like the case we did where you have a
linear gaussian system is probably the
ideal possible case for this
because obviously the average is the
linear operator and the for the gaussian
case
the mode and the actual average are the
same and so you have all these nice
properties none of which will hold
in the nonlinear general case and so i
think yeah in for that non-linear system
is almost certainly going to be much
much worse for that specific you know
issue yeah also to to on that i think
so so maybe so one question is is
whether
there is linear systems in which some of
the problems are going to go away but
maybe the
the right question is what happens in
the kind of non-linear systems that
that we expect in living system right
and
and what we know from living systems
often involves
bifurcations or critical points that
that lead to a long range correlations
and correlations that
that propagate through the whole system
and
and this kind of thing that can be very
difficult so so the kind of
isolation between internal and strong
states can be i think can be
challenging in in when this is the case
right
thanks for all these excellent points um
in complexity we often talk about
non-linear as being like
non-elephant animals it's like all of
them
so it's even harder certainly to make a
general
stance and baron that was a really
interesting point that as the state
space of what's possible
increases there may be more and more
edge cases and that kind of brings it
back to the question about
evolved systems not every parameter
combination of cells is going to be
functional
and so maybe we're only dealing with
that vanishingly small
amount or some other i'm not going to
you know go into technical details
on the fly but that could be one aspect
and also it was such an interesting
point during
the discussion when you explicitly
brought it back to evolution
like fitness is the law of the land in a
way
at a level that doesn't explain motor
behavior
in the moment to moment their nested
time scales and so of course there's
motor behavior that's maladaptive and
long run you wouldn't see that
under stationary ecology and dot dot dot
dot dot you start adding some
assumptions in
and it's just i think a very fruitful
mapping
that will be explored for time to come
with the relationship between popular
population
level claims under stationary
environments
population level claims under dynamical
environments and then individual level
claims
under stationary and and changing
environments so it's just a lot of
topics that come
into play and to have them
integrate these kinds of um points that
you're raising
which are often implicit errors in other
areas
they're being drawn together and brought
to the forefront in a way that is
quite novel
[Music]
okay again since the technical details i
believe
stand best in the presentation as you
provided as well as in the paper
we can take any questions but i think
that will be the place where
the discussion continues i just kind of
wanted to ask a few other
questions to provide a little context so
for maybe whoever wants to answer how
did you come to be studying
the question this way were you working
with the fep
and exploring new kinds of math or did
you
have more of experience with the
mathematics and then see the fep
coming up onto the radar like how did um
each of you come to be
working on it this way okay
yeah i'll go because i think i'll go
over so i mean i i wrote a review a few
years ago now
of the original energy principle at that
time it was
it was quite an enigmatic uh principle
not many people
understood it i mean the reason i
originally i didn't like it i didn't
like the idea
of the notion of representation seems to
be pregnant in the idea of the free
energy principle
kind of representing uh generative
models but i
actually came to like it's a cognitive
framework and i still do like it as a
as a cognitive framework uh and i still
still think within the regime
of describing essentially motor loops
abstract sensing
and cognitive systems it's very very
useful but then obviously then there's
been a rapid development of the free
energy principle into
uh into into a grander claim right to
find
this principle in the in physics in a
class of
physical systems uh and that's where
kind of i started working with miguel
and gail's got a real strong background
in statistical physics and that's
basically what's led us to this to kind
of really go back to some of those
assumptions
so i do separate the two things i think
there's the
still i'm very fine the the cognitive
account very appealing
even though we found these problems in
the in in these physics
uh examples
yeah yeah i all the uh
well i for like yeah for some i think
medium
i started doing involved with the the
principle more
recently i yeah for sometimes that is
something that i had on the radar but
but actually understand it what it
meant like it's always seen seemed kind
of
scary and challenging you know like the
equations and
and i guess that part of the motivation
for
doing or doing this work is is it was
to as a way of understanding what what
the theory consisted of because
you could go through the mathematical
descriptions and it's
often really hard to know and
what what they imply or what they mean
exactly
in the in the sense that they are
complicated maths right
and i guess that the the
during my research career that the way i
have
i have a hat for for understanding
complicated masses
by building models and this
understanding by building
philosophy that i so so i think that the
initial
attempts to to build this system it was
an attempt to
to really understand okay this step i
can for us
mathematically more or less what it
means but but let's have a model and
change parameters and play with it and
and so on right um so
so that was more or less the the journey
that and
and once having that first having the
model then say okay can i have something
more general
than just a some specific parameter so
let's
try let's see how we can have an
analytical solution i mean
and so on so so yeah so i think yeah
this
exercise is very fruitful both on a
personal level and also on a scientific
level because you can
on your way to learning you can develop
things that can be useful for the
theory more in general
awesome thank you for those answers
and also and i was just getting a
feedback right now from you
miguel so just mute while baron gives a
yeah okay go ahead yeah i just want to
follow up on the girl's point really
about just the importance of actually
trying to build these models
because i think from my perspective a
lot of developments and problems we
discovered basically came from
actually looking at specific models and
thinking hey this this doesn't quite
work out
as it says it should you know hey
because basically things have just
become an awful lot more clearer if you
actually try and build them
rather than just staring at these sort
of symbols on the page
and say i think that's really the key to
it to a lot of it you're simply trying
to construct a system where this works
and then say hey you know
if things aren't going quite as you know
the particular physics monograph says
they should be cool and it's so
interesting and maybe even appropriate
that action
became relevant for this inference
problem
so it's not just conceptual because we
must
be engaging in the literature and
conversation in the work
and going through it ourselves in order
to infer
deeper we can't just wait at square one
and look all the way to square one
thousand we have to be
working along the way individually and
maybe as a group too
so here's a question from the chat
brilliant talk
wonder if carl and others will respond
to challenges presented in this paper
also because the paper is written in
such coherent style
wonder what would you recommend for
beginners to study in the fep nice
question
what do you wish you knew at the outset
even if it's a new resource
what courses or topics would you
recommend
having a familiarity with or what are
the on-ramps for somebody who's not in
this
area of research and practice how can
they best be
on ramping themselves so i recommend
baron's github he's got a nice
repository of papers
uh which go from uh very introductory
papers to very sophisticated papers in
nicely organized ways i don't know if
you want to provide that
is it public publicly accessible
oh yeah publicly yeah i could post that
in the chat or something if you want
yeah say hello in the youtube chat and
then i'll make you a moderator and you
can post
links so yeah yeah
so then continue on that
yeah i mean regarding the actual
question about what to sort of start
with i think that depends a lot on what
you want to do
so there's kind of three big separate
topics in my mind
is that sort of the fep there's a
hardcore maths of the theory
as is presented in particular physics
and for that
i'm not sure there is necessarily a good
beginner's level resource at this point
like there is essentially i mean our
paper tries to go through quite
straightforwardly and then they have
you have the thomas par markup blankets
and stochastic thermodynamics paper
which sort of covers the main points but
it's not like a tutorial kendrick states
like this is xyz
and then really it's just the particular
physics monograph is where
most of that information is like there
isn't yet a really nice
laying out of it and obviously we kind
of try and do that in our paper but
obviously
we're also focused on the actual points
you want to make it's not just like
specifically tutorial
yeah i mean the other two things
obviously the active influence sort of
discrete database active inference
that people talk a lot about i think the
best resource for that at the moment is
probably landslide the caster's
review on that and then there's yeah
just then essentially there's some
several
of carl's papers which i think i talked
about in my github repository which is
kind of
going into more detail but lance's
review for that is really good and then
there's a sort of more continuous
state space predictive coding style
which i think i still i think chris's
his 2017 review is is the best for that
to be honest
so yeah
yeah i think chris is one is the one if
you wanted to understand the whole
the theory and all the math of the whole
walks through very nicely where profiles
like if you want to build a predictive
coding network which works and you
have that
is the way to go
if i can ask one note before miguel's
answer when you said newer science
do you see them as just historically
juxtaposed or do you see some of these
approaches
as encompassing one another or being
prerequisite to one another
so i think the idea is that the sort of
fep in the particular physics monograph
encompasses
all of them in that there you know the
idea is that these are just specific
models you know you have a spec have a
specific variation identity specific
generative model and then you work
through the math and you get these
these protest theories as carl calls
them out i mean i think in practice
though they stand they can stand alone
away from whatever the particular
physics monograph says because they
obviously make you know empirical
predictions about
the brain or whatever and so you can
actually test these and
so even if all all particular physics is
wrong then these things could be right
and vice versa
if all particular physics is perfectly
right and these things could just not be
what the brain is doing it could be
doing something else
so yeah i think they stand alone
although in theory the particular
physics monograph is kind of meant to
subsume them all
thanks for that response and miguel to
the original question
what would you recommend a beginner to
be learning
and looking into uh yeah i'm not so
sorry
for me so i think
yeah i started with thomas bar paper
about
markov blankets and promising geometry
and then
going back to the to the monograph of a
particular physics and
and but but it was
it was challenging because yeah it's
like there's
the maths are complex and and yeah it
was
and i kind of liked it was useful to uh
martin bill's paper a technical critical
of different
uh yeah of the free energy principle in
the sense
it was very technical and formal but it
was useful
that they tried to encapsulate the
different conditions
in a way similar to what we do here and
i think that was helpful
to try to to differentiate different the
different
steps which are not always so clear in
the
in the literature so so yeah i think
yeah i think there is at least for the
part regarding the free energy principle
as
described in the in in a particular
physics it's
and yeah we need maybe better tutorials
and
better yeah more materials that are
focused to
us introductions here thanks for these
responses
and i know in our acting lab and in many
other associated efforts that
the focus on accessibility and
communicating these
ideas in a way that's going gonna be
helpful to people from many backgrounds
is a top priority so way back in the
introduction you know 120 time steps ago
you talked about new visualizations and
it's definitely the case that
paper after paper will use some
classical
figures um let's just say and
i'm excited by visualizations and so was
curious
just maybe whoever wants to go in for it
what would the new representations do or
be
communicate what style or what made you
just wanting to explore visually and how
is that in feedback with the research
okay yeah i think that's interesting i
like at some point i keep looking
through the literature and it's
paper after paper the same the same
graph about the
brain sensor motor logo and so on
and yes sir so at some point it stops
being
useful right there because the like some
like its visualization can give
unique intuitions to some extent right
and
so and at some point i uh yeah
i wanted to know more about so so it was
not
it's not always straightforward okay
there's an arrow but what
does it mean or why is this
bi-directional or
and and yeah part so so the the
different
figures that we have where we developed
them with the idea of
okay how can we intuitively and
ex express these very complex uh
assumptions and ask how do you
have a figure of a solenoidal flow all
right
um this is really challenging and i
think i i i don't
i'm not sure if we did a good job there
but i think it's
in no that i think many intuitions about
the free energy principle are are really
hard to capture
because they are quite complex and i
think it's interesting to try to put in
the directions of
of having new images that try to at
least try to capture that
that intuitions and and what do they
mean or how to
yeah yeah because often i think you have
to
to read the theory based on your
intuition or covering with intuitions
the part that you don't understand yet
especially if you're learning and
this kind of thing i think is incredibly
useful in general in science right
chris or baron would you like to add on
that point
uh no i mean i just that we found it
hard right i mean
because there is some these so many
different types of interactions we want
to represent i mean typically
monolithic arrows between agent and
environment seems to dominate everything
right but when you start drilling down
into this
you have the difference between causal
and functional obviously people like
pearl and stuff i've done this in the
philosophy right they've been very clear
about different types of interaction but
i think in
uh especially modeling work it's it's
become
a bit uh clouded in lots of locations
especially in the area of the free
energy principle
but yeah i don't know whether uh i think
miguel did a really good job but
it does look complicated the the final
product is complicated looking right but
it does do justice uh to these different
types of interaction
yeah baron anything on that or no
yeah go for it yeah no i i would just
say that
i agree like i'm not naturally a visual
person who actually looks at the figures
but
i think just what miguel did was
actually really good and it's
something that if you actually look at
them and try and understand them it will
yield a lot of dividends in terms of
quickly getting to grasp on precisely
what's being said what's not being said
because yeah it's very easy to have into
this sort of hazy interaction without
knowing
what that really means it's the same
again as a geneticist it makes me think
of oh you know nodes are genes and edges
are interactions
which kind of those multiple classes and
does one paper use it one way and go to
the methods and it's one way in this
paper and it's another one in another
way but it's
being cited and so it takes a lot of
subtlety to pull back to that question
about what kind of interactions
are being discussed and then chris what
you just said there's like
um it's a high praise
for the work that it does justice
because that's what we
hope the bleeding edge does for the rest
of the knife and the handle is represent
visually on a manifold that doesn't
deceive
it's not drawing hard lines where none
exists
it's not making false positive or false
negatives or
false claims visually because visual
rhetoric
is how many people will learn and think
about these things
and so that's all it makes all the
difference whether there's a
bi-directional arrow
graphically or not because people are
going to unpack it especially if they're
not going to go into the
nth level of math they're going to
unpack it literally
and with the knowledge that that's what
the expert represented
in their um aim so yeah i really do
think it's particularly important
for this field because there is a
separation between this technical morass
that sits at the bottom
and obviously the the ambition and what
it promises so so many people are
attracted
to this particular theory and then but
not not everyone's got time to go in and
decipher that so that there's looking at
the level of these figures
and and trying to make you know
discourse and so on at that level so
it's
vital that those figures become very
clear and very
pointed in what they tried to
communicate and any kind of
lack of clarity is just going to send
the whole community off in the wrong
direction particularly if you
you're not the kind of person who wants
to go in and do the statistical physics
you want to do
more of the philosophy or or cognitive
science of these systems so it's vital
that we get them right
in this particular field particularly i
think yes
it's uh i think there's an xkcd cartoon
you know about where the fields are
arranged
but especially when working with the
theory itself
it should be lean and as
low dimensional as possible and not
anymore
because otherwise it will be unpacked in
ways that are just going to be
completely discordant
but if it can be represented in sort of
like a build in
or like an opt-in at this level instead
of trying to explain backwards from what
we could do in the future
in the math we need to start with the
axioms and clarify what they are
and then unpack those and then it's like
just like with any other area of theory
did you disagree with the axioms or did
you disagree with how they were applied
because those are the areas where
there's sort of controlled space
for discussion but then something like i
don't think it would work that way
in a human computer interface it's it's
neither here nor there
for the level of rigor that you approach
the questions with today
um so i can ask any other questions or
we can see if anyone else
posts in the chat but that was actually
one of my questions was are those all
the axioms
how do we represent axioms or how do we
even know
what those axioms are without getting
into like too much of a whole you know
incompleteness thing what are the axioms
were they what you put in a paper and
nothing else
those are necessary insufficient or is
there some other stuff happening
actually it's our ambition just to say
before i think i'll let michelle answer
that but
the the we have an ambition to write a
kind of more accessible version of this
paper
which hopefully we done in the next few
months so we want to do exactly that we
want to draw away from the
heart statistical physics and have this
paper underneath it but
then even be more even more clear
about the kind of overall narrative of
what we're suggesting here
uh and we'll we can answer those
questions that you asked very directly
hopefully but
for the specific case i'll let miguel uh
answer
up on you and then continue thank you
yeah yeah
yeah i think that the the pre-energy
principle is um no it has been an
evolving
theory and there is different versions
of eating
through the different papers in the 10
years that it has been
been proposed propulsion and
at least for me it was uh uh a difficult
job to to try to
get to to someone to summarize the
theory in that way or to
have the exact connections of steps
because also sometimes
the some descriptions are verbal but uh
and yeah i think that's yeah that's uh
important yeah an important avenue for
continuing
the research in this field is try to to
do more accessible
descriptions or more or try to
encapsulate them in in this way or try
to yeah
to solve this sequence more clearly or
at least for
an introductory purpose right yeah it's
been it's been very much a very uh
a living theory the french people i
found this when i wrote the
review back in the day which is that
there is this development that's very
clear in the uh
in the series of publications that comes
out and i think things
things have changed obviously as the as
they develop so
trying to see the consistency across
those types of things
um which is the fundamental action which
is later introduced and so on
is very difficult actually and again i
don't think it's a i don't i don't
criticize the office of this because i
think it is a living theory it's
something that's kind of really evolved
in the literature it's very complex one
so it had to be like that but yeah
hopefully as we go forward in the next
few years we can become more clear about
uh these things and we'll be more and
more people doing reviews and more
critical evaluations like
miguel's done which will will you know
further ground
uh this theory in a place where we can
all agree on and agree on the axioms
baron and then miguel okay yeah i just
want to say that yeah we should
definitely not consider
all the axioms and the free energy
principle at the moment to be completely
sort of fixed in stone
like i feel this is still living and
still evolving in many ways and there's
you know some cases where there's
questions about do we actually need this
axiom
can it be more general than this can it
be less general than this and stuff so i
think there's going to be a lot of more
foundational discussion
around the actual axioms underlying it
so and you know now the people are just
really just starting to tackle in a
particular physics in a really deep way
that i think that there will over the
next few years be lots of discussion
about this and hopefully
in a couple of years we'll have a much
more precise statement of you know what
the fop says what is needed
what isn't needed and you know how
everything fits together but at the
moment it's still in
a fair bit of flux like because really
deep critique
outside of karl's group on particular
physics is kind of just really starting
in the last year or so
thanks for that miguel yeah yes i also
always want to add that
okay so so we focus on on the free
energy principle and and this claim that
dynamical systems or self-progressing
systems behave as minimizing the primary
but i think that's
only yeah one part of the universe of
the
clearance investment you have the active
inference you have
the design of systems that explicitly
minimize the free energy and that's a
completely different field and
and often this is also mixed and not
sure
and yeah and there's sometimes a mix
between
so which is the the actions that i
invented in specifically papers no but
where are you where you are sitting in
your work is not always
clear for for anyone because of this
evolving
this evolution of the theory and these
interconnections and so on
and but i i think that yeah like uh
becoming more mature as they feel
becomes more mature this will be clear
because
sometimes this leads to confusion about
what the theory means no uh
when people say okay the free energy
principle shows that the every living
system is minimizing print oh okay
but um it's yeah so so it's different
when you
think of agents that do do it by by
design
or when you try to extend the claim to
other systems
so there is these different points of
view and these different sides of the
theory that
that yeah i i hope yeah i imagine that
they are going to evolve into more
comparative corpora compartmentalize
or even if they are interconnected but
in a way that they earthly area the
borders of the different planes and so
on
it's going to be uh an fep metaverse
that is appropriate for the online age
honestly
because when i think about how the
needle was pushed here github
and interactive computational notebooks
pre-prints like yours
live streams like the one that we're on
a discord server
you know a reading group that was
arranged by maxwell and others
10 years ago 20 years ago it would have
been like what
and it certainly wouldn't have been
accessible globally
so to see how the material and the
informational culture
and also social culture is changing
in a time when participatory science and
open science and all these kinds of
transdisciplinary
ideas are coming to the fore
it's just an awesome contribution so
um i'll offer any final thoughts from
the chat and each of you a final
um word but just to say from the lab
that we really
appreciate your willingness to you know
jump on on short notice
and work on it and share it in this way
and also with these exciting
directions that you've planned out and
expect
i'm actually going to say i completely
agree with you and i have to you know
shout out to people like maxwell ramstad
who
organized these discord servers which
are you know really
promulgating this debate uh and why
communities which are really valuable
for
uh as infrastructure for us people like
us to come in and do this type of
research so yeah
i completely agree with that this this
new infrastructure there is really
important for this type of stuff
aaron any last comments and then miguel
of course yeah
final word you know i just want to echo
what chris said really about just
the sheer importance of the reading
group max were organized because i think
that's where you know i
i learned an awful lot about how
particular physics works and you know
how
everything goes through in that
monograph and i think a lot of people
did there as well like i think
that reading would have really built up
enough expertise to you know make papers
like this and obviously similar to
modern stuff and just generally
get everything together probably lots of
stuff in the next year or so coming out
actually made all of that possible
really and so yeah also this is a family
like if
you're interested in learning more about
the fop like email maxwell because he
has recordings of all the reading group
meetings
and so that's probably going to be a
really good for a good another lockdown
i think
yeah so yeah a lot of records will be
lots of material there
yeah if you want to really drill down
into technicalities and those recordings
will probably be really good
as well great and um
miguel if you would like to give any
last comments
um yeah yes well yes yes
as you said as i think yeah um partly as
chris and bryan say that i i cannot join
late
to the group and just attend to the last
sessions but it was really
helpful to to dig through the some of
the discussions that
took place there and i think in general
what so
i think in general yeah like what could
make the field advance is to to make
things successful in different ways and
and this can be through resources
through communities
and also through more transparent
models or more easier to follow guides
through the maps and i think the part of
the difficulties in the field is that
there is
this a disconnection between people that
is doing mathematical work and people
that is doing philosophical work
and not only here but i think in
cognitive science in general or
or even more deeper
abuse of systems biology and so right
and
and that this multi level yeah i think
it's very valuable this this efforts in
in in trying to make things more
accessible and easier to follow
from yeah for people for from multiple
disciplines
i think that's a very valuable effort
that we should try to do
collectively because that's the only way
and thanks a lot for hosting the session
thank you
we always talk about tools ideas and
people
they're a triple helix and so thanks for
making it happen with all those
today thank you very much for that peace